las calles de melbourne una ciudad de 5
millones de habitantes siguen estando en
su mayoría desiertas el lunes se levantó
el toque de queda nocturno después de
casi dos meses pero la orden de quedarse
en casa sigue en vigor algunos
residentes están impacientando con las
restricciones que dicen son demasiado
estrictas dado que sólo se registraron
cinco nuevos contagios por el virus en
el estado de victoria en las últimas 24
horas el encierro durará por lo menos
otros dos meses como dice dan andrews
hasta finales de octubre entonces qué
hacemos de repente no podré pagar el
alquiler y hay millones de personas en
victoria que están en el mismo barco
además de levantar el toque de queda las
industrias de la construcción y la
manufactura pueden volver a funcionar
las guarderías pueden reabrir y los
pequeños servicios religiosos pueden
reanudarse pero los negocios
considerados no esenciales sigan
teniendo prohibido la reapertura los
restaurantes solo están disponibles para
pedidos a domicilio el primer ministro
del estado de victoria advirtió a los
residentes que no se volvieran
complacientes
estamos tan cerca de poder dar un gran
paso
un gran paso hacia esa kobe normalidad y
empezamos a hacer cosas que sabemos en
el fondo que no son correctas entonces
podemos poner en riesgo todo lo que
hemos construido todo lo que los
victorianos han dado dicen
australia ha sido relativamente exitosa
en frenar la propagación del cob y 19
con poco más de 27.000 contagios y solo
875 decesos para una población de 25
millones el gobierno de victoria dijo
que una mayor relajación de las medidas
podría tener lugar el 19 de octubre si
el promedio cae por debajo de los 5
nuevos casos por día